this lockdown has become so political
lefties support staying home and
supporting the health service the
right-wingers want to work and support
the economy obviously I'm generalizing
and the science behind both arguments
that's politicized as well take for
example professor Neil Ferguson burst
Ronson's lockdown news Ferguson's
research and some say overly pessimistic
modeling is what led to the stricter
lockdown in the UK and his main concern
is keeping covert case numbers as low as
possible on the other side of the
argument there's the Swedish school like
Balazs a Swede professor Johan Gatica
he's one of the brains behind Sweden's
more lace a fair shall we call it or
even fatalistic approach to the lockdown
they haven't closed down schools they
haven't closed down restaurants and they
still allow gatherings of up to 50
people give you is that debts saved by a
lockdown will happen once it's lifted
anyway website unheard interviewed both
of them this past month and concluded
that this may not be a case of one of
them being good and one of them being
bad that they're just looking at the
science and coming to different
conclusions as scientists do
unfortunately for all of us right now we
are the lab mice in this experiment and
more importantly neither of them know
what's gonna happen either